Transcriptor: Pierre Albiero
Revisor: Yasmin Klär
El principal consejo de los grandes
pensadores para ser innovador
es ser tú mismo.
¿Pero si yo te pregunto directamente quién
sos y qué tenés para ofrecer?
¿Sabes la respuesta?
A veces ser uno mismo es tan abstracto
y tan ajeno que es una
de las ironías más grandes.
No sabemos cómo ser nosotros mismos ni
cómo descubrir qué podemos ofrecer.
Me da risa ver en redes sociales vídeos
que son la copia de la copia de la copia
de los originales, sin intención
de generalizar.
Hay una mayoría que lo único
que hace es imitar.
Te doy ejemplos.
Los que hacen podcast ponen sus títulos
en los espacios en blanco encima del
vídeo, en tutoriales de maquillaje,
enseñan el producto y aplican.
Enseñan el producto y aplican.
Los de viajes y tours siempre empiezan
con la toma alta del dron.
Los bailarines hacen los pasos típicos
y así puedo seguir y seguir.
Alguien hizo todo esto de primero y los
que copian probablemente lo hacen porque
les gustó o porque creen que así se hacen
las cosas, o porque creen que esa es la
fórmula para hacerse viral.
Muchos podrían decirme así , pero
esas cosas son necesarias.
El tema del podcast, enseñar el producto
que se utiliza, la toma de ubicación o
seguir la tendencia.
Y yo respondería toda la razón que es
necesario,
pero tenéis que hacerlo igual a los demás.
No hay alguna forma de hacerlo diferente.
Y es ahí donde se debe reflexionar, porque
si me decís que esa es la única
forma, seguirá siendo la copia.
Pero si quiere ser innovador, tendrás
que tomar el camino más difícil.
Ahora, ¿cómo lo hago?
Me di la tarea de entender que fue lo que
hicieron los originales y descubrí cinco
factores en común que me gustaría
compartirte. Uno:
El contenido que puedes disfrutar
hoy significa que ya existe.
Úsalo únicamente como inspiración.
Ponle mucha atención para que te presiones
a nunca hacer lo mismo.
Dos: Utilizar todos tus talentos y
conocimientos, aunque una cosa no tenga
nada que ver con la otra.
Tal vez es la combinación perfecta
para la innovación.
Al inicio todos me decían que el
periodismo y la danza no se podían
combinar, pero eran las únicas cosas que
conocía y al atreverme a combinarlas
nacieron ideas y proyectos de los
que me siento muy orgullosa.
Tres: Recordar que hay público para todo.
A veces nos limitamos porque creemos que
nuestra forma de ser no es lo suficiente
simpática, intelectual,
dulce o lo que sea.
Que no te dé miedo mostrar tu personalidad
ni tu forma de ver el mundo.
Poco a poco se va creando una comunidad.
Es solo tener paciencia y serte fiel.
Cuatro: No te dejes llevar
por los comentarios.
Ser innovador no es lo usual.
Por lo tanto, al inicio puede existir una
etapa de incomodidad del público.
Pero si en tu cabeza tienes todo el
sentido del mundo, no permitas que nadie
te haga dudar de algo de lo
que estabas convencido.
Siempre he dicho que la intuición
es como un superpoder.
Hazle caso y cinco: Obligate a ponerle
tu chispa a las tendencias.
Unirse a ellas es importante por
exposición
y porque todos están hablando de eso.
Pero recordar siempre diferenciarte
y adaptar tu tipo de contenido
a las tendencias.
Naciste siendo único.
Tu vida está llena de experiencias.
La combinación de todo te da la
oportunidad de proponer e innovar.
Dejar de esconderte siendo
la copia de alguien más.
Porque hay un espacio en el mundo
esperando para que vos y tu idea empiecen
a brillar.